سعاده عار ما بي منتخب المغرب العربي الذي
يسطر تاريخ العرب في بطولات كاس العالم
وايضا مثل ما قال الشيخ تميم كاس عالم
العرب وبيتوج بها العرب ان شاء الله
كانت مباراه في المغرب العربي احنا في
الدوحه ابدا في بلد عربي
فخر العرب
تنظيمات وعلى كل شيء والله يعطيكم الصحه
والعافيه ومشكورين يا جماعه الخير
[موسيقى]
الحمد لله
تفضل
المغرب يعني في لحظه قلنا النيه ان
الرجلاجي قبل المونديال قبل اعلان قال
للمغاربه اعملوا النيه وان شاء الله غدر
في العارضه وتخرج
وهذه النيه
داخل الاستاذ كان موجود اليوم
44.767
بدا يخرج من هذا من هذه البوابه الرئيسيه
كما تشاهد الحسود يغادرون
ملعب الثمامه هنا ويتجهون للاحتفالات في
مناطق مختلفه البعض منهم يتجه الى الى همم
سوق واقف البعض الاخر يتجه الى اللؤلؤه
على الكورنيش الى مناطق يعني عده وجميع
هنا يعني يحتفل
والفرحه في عيونهم همم الجميع هنا يعني
يظهر
تظهر وهو في اجمل حاله كما بنقول وهو
يحاول طبعا الكلام عن المغرب تفضل شو بدك
تحكي لنا عن النجاح
كيف رونالدو
صوتي راح احكي في رونالدو
[تصفيق]
نيمار
لا لا لا لا لا لا
المغرب وجميع يعني انت حامل علم عمان انت
من عمان
الحمد لله كانت الاجواء طيبه والحمد لله
فوز المنتخب المغربي يستاهلوا المنتخب
المغربي ان شاء الله ان شاء الله باذن
الله النهائي المغرب ان شاء الله باذن
الله
القديس
بوك
ضد اسبانيا